one one of the why's the profit i said
um she you know was laying with him
and then she you know her period hit and
she had to go
kind of sneak out of bed to go get
cleaned up and stuff and the procedure
that i sent him noticed that she was
kind of subtly sneaking away
and um he said when you you know when
you when you're finished when you
come back and and come back close to me
come even closer to me
because in that state she may feel a bit
impure like maybe i shouldn't be close
to him
possibly said him he knew that he sensed
it from her and he's like when you're
done come back and get even closer to me
to make her feel you know loved and
appreciated small things like that
that go you know the extra mile jordan
peterson talks a lot about people need
such little motivation in life
they need such little motivation and if
you can't even give that
how are you going to call yourself a
leader let alone a man right
and another example i want to give is
you know the one we all know when the
prophet was eating with aisha
and she would drink from the cup he
would turn it to drink from the same
spot
right this is not a word he didn't have
to say anything he just did something
subtle
but obviously it filled her it filled
her heart with love
a more uh critical example would be
when a woman her son died and the cross
said i said him i forgot what he said
but he went up to her when she was
crying at his grave
and he said something solace in him and
she yelled at the prophet
there are ayat in the quran saying don't
raise your voice of the prophet sam
right
and the process of he didn't pull this
out and say you don't yell at me i'm the
prophet right
he walked away he knew this is not the
time
and he walked away and as a man we need
to know sometimes when to walk
away another big thing but this this
just shows how deep
this entire um practice is
so once you understand emotional
intelligence as
a general you know mechanism or uh
general concept and you understand the
four things that i mentioned
then once you have these mechanisms down
you'll operate a lot better in life
look at your own mindset look at how you
think like oh i want to get this
so then i'll be good like i want to be
making x amount of money
so then i don't have to worry about like
paying bills or
paying for food or going traveling and
doing this and that
um i want to lose this body fat so then
i could be defined so then i don't have
to think about like i
have this much fat on my body i want to
have this much muscle on my body on my
frame
to where it's like when i look at myself
i'm happy with what i see
it's like our mind's always trying to
get to that state where it's like okay
i'm good i don't have to
do anything else now imagine being in
jannah where it's like
you don't have to make money you don't
have to
eat food you can eat food if you want to
enjoy yourselves
but you don't have to right you don't
you're not
you're not uh at the mercy
of uh like your vices if you have any
vices
like you know sex i'm sure bro i'm
sure we could have sex in general but
proper sex
and without feeling like we're addicted
to it
without feeling like we're being
controlled by it so it's like i don't
know about y'all but that seems
that seems pretty perfect
too guys and girls welcome back to teeth
again we got your boy fired we got your
boy anjo we got your boy robbie
and if it's your first time here hit
that subscribe button we are the realest
podcast out here
and if you're returning come become a
patreon
we post some exclusive content there and
that's how we know you're really part of
the ttm community
now before we get started guys i know i
didn't run this by you guys
this is the first time that the
subscribers and viewers that are
watching this are gonna hear this as i
tell the two boys here
but you know what i was thinking you
coming out
well yeah we're gonna we're gonna we're
gonna all do that as a
three-way bro but not not right now i
think it's we're too young in our career
for that you know
what i was thinking is uh to get more
controversy
we got to have more views right so we'll
we'll hold that off on that
what i'm trying to invite our viewers is
if they have a story if they have a
revert journey that they want to share
if they have anything bro
islam is an all-encompassing way of life
right
so you coming into islam if you have
some story that you want to share you
think it's going to be motivating or you
just want to come
you know hang out with the boys chop it
up what i was thinking is
we let this open invite thing where
different viewers can come
different subscribers can come if they
revert it to islam if they have some
type of story about the journey to islam
they share it then we take all the
moments all the compilations
and we can either put in one big video
something like
you know subscribers rebirth stories
something like that or we
you know release them one by one just so
you know we could spread more message
people know that it's something normal
to not have this cognitive dissonance
about islam forever and beyond the fence
but just to take action and your life
just goes uphill from there
yeah i think that's a good idea
inshallah i agree it'd be like it'd be a
pretty sick livestream
uh having people come on i think it'd be
pretty good
very uh you know emotionally intelligent
of you masha'allah
um bro speaking about emotional
intelligence
you you see masculinity today and i know
we dropped some episodes
uh you know in the last few weeks that
you know these viewers saw
specifically about just being a man and
i get it bro
there is a hardcore over agenda against
men
both of you agree but at the same time
there's another side of that coin right
our viewers are talking about
oh why don't you talk about you know the
the softness or the
gentleness of the prophet salallahu and
it's like we will but
before we get into all that you got to
realize masculinity
at the forefront is just being a man
right and being a man isn't just one
thing it's not just being hard it's not
just being
too aggressive there's this whole realm
of echo of intellect specifically
emotional intelligence
that a lot of people miss out on they
neglect right
they they see what masculinity should be
from you know
social media uh hollywood netflix and
they think that oh
it's supposed to be hard it's supposed
to be aggressive blunt
disrespectful right that's not the way
at least for islam
right but it's also not to be too
restrictive of yourself too much
restraint isn't good either that perfect
balance
is where emotional intelligence comes in
rami
take it away man what are your thoughts
on what i said so far i want to figure
it out
yes i agree hundred percent i think is
100 accurate
uh especially the fact that uh
masculinity we're being stripped of it
nowadays
and um when we turn to society to teach
us what masculinity
is but that's the same driving force
that's stripping us of our masculinity
it's going to give us a misconstrued
version of it
or something that's not even close to
what masculinity is and we're going to
think that's it
and i was talking about this last night
with somebody there's basically two
extremes
and i think you mentioned both of them
there's the extreme
of men not being masculine at all
they're just literally feminine men
they're just soy boys and the other
extreme is basically
uh the the men that think they're so
hard they're so
masculine that they cannot be caught
dead doing anything that's
even resembles femininity in the
slightest
whether it's smiling at your wife
hugging her anything
anything small like that they can't do
it and these are both extremes and
they're both problems i don't know which
one
started and birthed the other but these
were both extreme so where the prophet
salallahu where did he you know draw the
line where was he
he was at the perfect balance and i
won't say it's exactly in the middle
like half half
obviously more masculine but when he did
kind things out of his heart that
seems feminine he did it from a
masculine standpoint
as a man right mending his own shoes
so we can use them to go out and do work
and give dawah and so on and so forth
right so subhanallah man it's
it's really sickening nowadays and
the issue is we cannot propagate
men doing feminine things before we
propagate masculinity
it's because when you have a masculine
man he
even if he has bad morals you can teach
him good morals insha'allah and he
already has a masculinity to act on them
if you take a feminine man what is he
gonna do
be a woman that's there's no there's no
good in that even
and don't get me wrong like if
somebody's like you know a bit more soft
or something that doesn't make them
you know bad or less of a man or not a
man
it's just that the prophet he said that
the strong believer is better than the
weak believer but they both have
they both have good so if anything we
have these two extremes
we need to tear everyone to being
masculine
get them on the same masculine page and
then teach them islam teach them morals
so then they know that okay these women
have a right over me
and as a man i'm gonna give them that
right and i'm gonna protect them
feminine people can't do that they're
too scared they're too cowardly
cowardly to to you know stand up in that
sense
so you can't go around to all the world
and teach
it's okay to to you know to do this uh
feminine thing or to act this way or
whatever before you teach them
fundamentally masculinity
as a whole and teach them islam and
within that islam you'll find that it's
fine to do this and to do that and the
prophet isn't
it and you should emulate his character
that's my my general overview of it man
i'ma agree with you but i'm also going
to disagree in the sense that
i don't think a man should be soft
i think a man should know how to soften
in certain situations but
he should never be soft like the soft
just listen to me if someone says soft
if i say
soft what's the first thing that comes
up in your head
sponge sponge yeah
spongebob scary for me i think of a yarn
ball
a yawn listen
when i hear soft bro i think femininity
yeah i think like a woman like that
caressing love that affection
yeah you know that warming breaks soft
brother
when a woman is embracing you like
y'all's moms yeah
right when your mother embraces you
that's a soft
embrace like your mom your mom ain't
coming at you and like hugging you too
you can't breathe no more
nah she's like softly hugging you with
love yeah at least you know
inshallah that's how it is but like when
i even when i hear soft that's what i
think of i think of feminine when i hear
hard i think of
masculine yeah yeah yeah right but it's
yeah going sorry yeah so a man
should be hard by nature but emotional
intelligence comes in where it's like he
should know when to
soften because it's like you don't have
to be
balls out to the wall hard all the time
where it's like like you were saying
you can't smile at someone whether that
be your wife whether it be your family
member whether it be some random
stranger
yeah yeah you can't laugh you can't
enjoy a conversation with someone
and really i speak from experience man
like i was there i was at a point
one time where i was like i felt so soft
because of what i had gone through in my
childhood that i was like you know what
i gotta toughen up i gotta become hard
and then i became too hard and like i
just didn't wanna talk to anyone i
became very secluded very isolated
and i was like man this is no way to
live um
let me let me go a little bit of that
bro romney hold you down real quick if
you feel like you're gonna forget
you can uh you can write it down and
tell us right now but remember man
emotional intelligence but you got to
have that intelligence too so shout out
to rami for uh
always remembering his thoughts even
though people cut him off now
with that being said first point i
wanted to make is
muscle when you think of masculinity i
think of muscle right you guys might
think of something else but when you
think of femininity
wallahi bro the second you said what do
you think of the first thing
yeah i said yarn ball because i'm trying
to be cornball and make a joke but
real talk the first thing i think of
when i think of femininity is skin
that's it bro i don't think of muscle
i think of skin and think about it bro
album american made a video about this
that
when you think of skin anatomically it's
on top of the muscle right
the muscle without the skin cannot
function but
without the muscle the skin doesn't have
anything to bind to it doesn't have
anything to hold on to
right the skin is also more vulnerable
to
and susceptible to harsh environments
harsh climates right
so it's a little more sensitive right it
needs all these things like blood flow
um proper you know conditioning you know
exfoliation
hydration it needs all these things
right to function just like
femininity but masculinity in and of
itself is the core
it's it's the muscle it's the building
block it's the foundation
without the muscle there is no skin but
without the skin the muscle can't thrive
right so
they're both important and anal you know
goes alhamdulillah a lot into this how
men and women we have both but what he
was outlining how
you know you you said you were soft most
of your life right
you were a product of society you were
weak
ah never said that i said that i
felt soft because of the abuse that i
went through
all right so you felt soft right it felt
soft
because of external conditions because
of society because of programming
because of familial circumstances right
whether you were soft or you felt soft
at the end of the day if i asked you
who are you you'd say soft and because
of this softness
you had to go through all this hardship
with all this
resentment and anger and then when you
finally realized
bro you're not really soft like you as a
man your your energy your fitrah who you
are the way allah
made you it's hard it's a man but not
hard in the
in the you know other sense i'm talking
about you are a real man
right so my point being is when allah
created you to be hard
a real man and you realize that that
came into you
what did you do bro you said you went
overboard with it you stopped smiling
you stopped
you stopped doing this you had to act
more manly
and you have to make this conscious
effort to always be across as a man
right
now in in society again what's the word
for that called
there's a word for it i'm not sure bro
compensating compensating i was even
overcompensating but
the point i'm being the point that i'm
propagating towards is
this is the three levels of manhood that
i always talk about
i've been preaching about this level one
is angel before right
me before rami today now i'm playing
rami before as well
it's literally every man until they
realize that
this whole matrix blue pill propaganda
that they've been taught
about do this do that this is what you
know basically what your mama told you
what your sisters told you what your
teachers told you mostly women
it's a lie bro it's not really what
reality is
you you're literally bending over
backwards to make everyone happy
right you are literally doing everything
you're giving too much of yourself
you're putting other people first
because you feel like if you don't
they're gonna leave you they're gonna
abandon you your only value is
just being selfless right this is your
ideology
now you then you know go through
hardship you go through abuse like it's
brother here
you go through realizations in life like
this brother down here you go through
different experiences and something
clicks within you you realize damn bro
since i've been too weak all my life and
too soft
i gotta do the opposite now right and i
get it
you do things that are completely
contrary and they might work sometimes
right like instead of being too weak you
become too overt
you start cussing you start being hella
direct you start being
way too up in everyone's face and i get
it sometimes it works sometimes people
respect that
but by and large you're still doing it
from a position of weakness
why the level one guy is giving too much
of himself putting everyone first
because he feels like if he doesn't
he's not valuable that's scarcity level
two is still scarcity
trust me because level two you're
holding back everything because you feel
like even if you give a sliver of
yourself
of you know attention time you smile
just like you said
people are going to hold people are
going to take you for granted bro you
you're hurt
you got this chip on your shoulder you
feel like if if you do even
anything you you give a girl um you know
a compliment you
uh you know you smile your wife you help
your friend move
houses right you're gonna be seemed weak
this is still scarcity
yes people will kind of you know respect
you more
than level one they'll know you stand
your ground but it's only the insecure
people
that fall for you when you're level two
because these people
are insecure themselves and you at level
two are still insecure level three
though this is what we're talking about
fellas and girls watching this level
three
as a man is when you perfectly integrate
what rami was speaking about
it's that balance between the two it's
you're not level one
because you're not giving everything you
give when you want to give
if you really like something your wife
did you compliment it if you really want
to call someone you don't wait for them
to call you like a like a little
princess that needs attention
and wants them to think about them you
call them first bro there's no ego
right and you're not like level two
right
in the sense that you're not holding
everything back when you want to give
something you give
right but it's from a position of
strength if they still take it for
granted okay then you deal with it call
us but
you don't you're not walking on
eggshells all the time trying to not be
seen like a sin
but also overly wanting to be seen like
a man
right you just become a man you're not
concerned about
seeming like a real man this is level
three level three has
emotional intelligence right level three
puts themselves first but only so
they can eventually make sure everyone
else comes with them and for other
people
i had two right so rami
i want you to get into that this panel i
just want to add to that
um actually first let me say it on hill
i'm glad you mentioned what you
mentioned before because i know they're
going to
be people at home that have that same
line of thinking because when i say
soft or hard i'm not referring to ends
of a spectrum
i'm just i'm referring to like a
demeanor right
um and you when you said there like a
man should soften
you're talking about the demeanor his
demeanor should be able to take a soft
approach in that stuff in certain
situations right
that's what i say that's what i mean
when i say like um has
the ability to be softer can be softer
whatever it is
uh so we're on the same page with that
and you you worded it a little bit
better than i did so just
thank you for clearing it up and um yeah
i agree 100 with what you said it was
like i was i was having these thoughts
as you were speaking
then you would say subhanallah i'm glad
you know we're all in line with the
thinking on this
um what was that last point you said
because it kind of rang a bell in my
head
about level three you gotta have
emotional intelligence bro you do things
out of abundance
right everything is is out of abundance
level one
has no purpose they're always on their
phone to text the girl back
because they realize bro if i don't what
if she finds another guy yeah level two
you still got no purpose bro you're
still at home but you're purposely
texting her back hours later
because you realize damn bro if i seem
too available what is she gonna do she's
gonna then still leave me
level three bro you're on your purpose
you got time you texted you don't got
time
you don't text you're simple bro yeah
100 um i agree hundred percent
mashaallah
so damn what was my point emotional
intelligence abundance
abundance um yeah so take over for a
second bro
it's okay i got my thought i got
alhamdulillah but uh if you want to go
i'll let you go i don't mind if i'm
gonna go ahead
if it's fresh go ahead so um level one
and two are still
they're not acting they're reacting and
this is an issue because as men as
you know people we have to take action
right if you live a life reacting then
you'll never get ahead because you're
always one step behind because you're
going off of what you know outside is
saying or someone else is doing
so when you get a message from a girl
you must immediately respond that's your
reaction
right this only happens when you're not
taking action in life
because if you're taking action you get
a message okay i'll get back to it in a
second let me finish what i'm doing
um and then the other one you're also
reacting it's just a
it's a intentional delayed reaction to
it so you seem a certain way and it's
still
for the perception of other people but
the third person and i would say the top
tier amongst the third people
uh the third group would be you know the
the good muslim the person who does it
for the sake of allah
because this person the reason he knows
he has to better himself
you know and then help people is because
he knows in stage
one when you're trying to help everyone
you're not you don't have the foundation
yourself
you can't help someone it's like a poor
person giving money they don't have to a
poor person
you don't have much to offer and this
person understands okay i need to build
myself
up and put myself uh you know in this
position where i can help people
and it doesn't hinder me because what's
the point if you just end up burning out
and this is the emotional intelligence
it's it's the ability
to i think sheikh mikhail if you want to
shout out his book right now go ahead
but um
this brother masha'allah first i'm gonna
i'm gonna move the carrots aside bro
the ones that are on her loves with
ranch
you know you know bro here's the book i
have it right
with me right here yeah with the this
book is called
with the heart in mind yeah the moral
and intelligent
moral and emotional intelligence of the
prophet
now this is by mikhail ahmed smith jake
smith
now why do we find this book valuable
what are some of the gems in this book
right a lot of people
including myself yeah i went into a trip
to the mountains with brother rama
and you know we were having just real
discussions about just the two of us
and a lot of the discussions led me down
a path to realize
that yes the prophet sallallahu alaihi
sallam
was a man a hard man when he needed to
be yeah
he was also soft with aisha
allah with with all of his wives with
all of it all the people when
the time permitted that was not his
default setting
right and i believe my interpretation a
lot of these hadith before you go on
they're to show that the prophet
salallahu had a normal life too
right shout out to mufti meng bro yes
a lot of people think it's only about
knitting it's not
but when you see this video i'm sure his
intention was just to show people
that bro we're normal too we're not
always here
doing some other ish on these planes
like fox news wants to show you
we're normal people too yeah and if you
gave us a chance
we'll show you that but i'm sure that
was his intention just to show he's a
father too he spends times with his kids
too
you know but i'll let you go on bro
because this book
going on during our talk me and you when
we were in the mountains yeah we talked
about a lot of stuff you told me a lot
of stuff that the prophet saws did
which i want you to get into after your
point about the examples of how he had
emotional intelligence
but essentially you know you can correct
me if i'm wrong
i know you can give me two cents too but
i feel like emotional intelligence
has more to do with your actions than
your words
that's true did y'all go to uh brokeback
mountain
i don't think so no that's the one we're
gonna go
all four of us with me you uh angel
and gabriel listen i'm not going on
brokeback violence bro
no remember uh shake fallout to sleep
said uh we're gonna drought you put you
on that plane
listen i'm not going on brokeback vine
what's wrong with that do you know what
brokeback mountain is
yeah but but okay romney what's wrong
with brooklyn
i have no idea
all right we'll leave that out yeah
all right let's meet that um yeah so i
wanna i wanna say what i'm gonna say
inshaallah i wanna pass it on to unhill
because i know he has some some you know
wise words to share in sha allah
i agree i think actions in general speak
louder than words you know as
the old saying goes actually speaks
louder than words and it's because
leading by example
is a lot better than just telling people
what to do to the point where we have
people saying
do as i say not what i do just to cover
up their own
you know slobby tendencies to to not be
a man of their word
um but no leading by example is one of
the
best things for a person to do as a
leader
because this environmental psychology we
have you know being able to perceive
someone doing something says a lot more
than someone saying it
because it shows more than just words
and meaning it's
they're going out of their way
physically putting themselves on the
line to do something
and this has a whole string of you know
maybe it's courage
bravery emotions behind it and you can
look at this person and say subhan allah
they're actually doing this and just
seeing that will motivate you a lot more
than just hearing about it
uh because you get to see it in real
time so that's why in general
actions are speak loud in the words and
the prophet saw was the best in this
right he was the best in this
not only did he advise beautifully
sallallahu
in human form right the person who
obeyed the quran to the t
and seeing that in action subhan allah
you know
the sahaba dilemma they actually
obviously had the greatest example for
them
so subhanallah emotional intelligence
the way sheikh
mikhail breaks it down is to four
categories one it's it's recognizing
emotion being able to say this person's
upset or they're happy
or they're mad or they're excited
understanding the emotion understanding
where it could come from
right why they may feel this way if i
say this will it make them feel worse
you know what can i say to make them
feel better um
um using the emotion to bring about
positivity in the person
positive change in the person for
example
if a person passes away encouraging them
to to give sadhaka in their in that
person's name
is increasing the you know increasing
them in good and a person may be more
inclined to do that in that state
out of you know out of the emotion and
then four is one of the most important
ones is regulating your own emotions
being able to control and regulate your
own emotions people
men don't understand how important this
is if you cannot do this
i as a young man i'm going to say you
cannot call yourself a man if you're not
able to do this
because you're just basically going
berserk if you believe masculinity is is
control and power you're essentially
powerless when you get emotional
because you just go berserk you don't
have control of yourself so people think
men think that being masculine is when
you get angry you you hit things
that's the most i don't want to say most
feminine thing to do and refer to kind
of
jordan peterson saying that masculinity
is is uh
order and femininity is chaos or but he
has statistical research to back that up
but it's just not very masculine of you
to do so
regulating your own emotions is one of
the most important aspects and once you
get that
down you can work on the other steps and
and you know see the prosthetist
and how he regulated his emotions and
how he um
motivated people with their uh their
emotions for example
um he noticed and this is all from
sheikh
uh mikhail and he gave a lecture on it
inshallah i if you want to go watch you
go watch it it's two parts i think
he mentioned that one one of the why's
the prophet saws she you know was laying
with him
and then she you know her period hit and
she had to go
kind of sneak out of bed to go get
cleaned up and stuff and the process i
said i'm noticed that she was kind of
subtly sneaking away
and um he said when you you know when
you when you're finished when you
come back and and come back close to me
come even closer to me
because in that state she may feel a bit
impure like maybe i shouldn't be close
to him
possibly said him he knew that he sensed
it from her and he's like when you're
done
come back and get even closer to me to
make her feel you know
loved and appreciated small things like
that that goal
you know the extra mile jordan peterson
talks a lot about people need such
little motivation in life they need such
little motivation
and if you can't even give that how are
you going to call yourself a leader
let alone a man right and another
example i want to give
is you know the one we all know when the
prosthetist was eating with aisha
and she would drink from the cup he
would turn it to drink from the same
spot
right this is not a word he didn't have
to say anything he just did something
subtle
but obviously it filter it filled her
heart with love
a more uh critical example would be
when uh a woman uh her son died
and prospered i said i forgot what he
said but he went up to her when she was
crying at his grave
and he said something solely to him and
she yelled at the prophet
there are ayat in the quran saying don't
raise your voice of the prophet sam
right
and the prophet said he didn't pull this
out and say you don't yell at me i'm the
prophet right
he walked away he knew this is not the
time
and he walked away and as men we need to
know sometimes we want to walk
away another big thing but this this
just shows how deep
this entire um practice is
so once you understand emotional
intelligence as
a general you know mechanism or uh
general concept and you understand the
four things that i mentioned
um then once you have these mechanisms
down you'll operate a lot better
in life
[Music]
you all know about when uh the prophet
sallam's wife
would be a little you know displeased
with him
angered just emotional not really
feeling a honor with him
she would she would call when she would
refer to um
i believe it was when she was referring
to allah she would say the the lord of
uh
ibrahim yeah but when she was pleased
with him when she was
feeling good with him she would refer to
allah as the lord of you know
allah right it's like little things that
he would be aware of these things
and you know he would say oh you're
upset right now and she would say
uh what do you mean how do you know i'm
upset and then he would say oh because
you you refer to allah
as the lord of ibrahimovic right or me
and you were talking about this
this lady that would walk the old lady
that would walk with uh
so she was walking with the messenger of
allah and what was she telling him
so so first i want to start from the
beginning so she was carrying some items
so she was an elderly lady i believe in
older lady and she was carrying some
items and the prosthetic went to help
her carry the stuff
so he helps her carry the stuff and he's
walking with her to wherever she's
heading maybe her house
to help her drop the stuff off and the
whole time
she's talking about this man named
muhammad who's this horrible
person who's coming to ruin our way of
life and he's lying about all this stuff
and he's this and that and he's just
she's just talking ish about him
and he's right there so part of me he's
right there salallahu
and she didn't know that this was you
know muhammad saw islam
do you want to finish off the story go
for a man
take it away all right so as they're
walking and she's talking you know all
this
all this ish about this man named
muhammad now the prophet just sits there
listening to him he walks with her or
listening to her he's walking with her
just listening to her and
you know by the time they're finished
she's like oh you know i didn't i didn't
get your name what's your name
and he's like i'm that muhammad that you
were talking about
and just imagine the emotion that she
felt in that moment like
i think this guy's such a horrible
person right i think he's a horrible
person
but the whole time he was listening to
me talk
all this ish about him and he didn't say
sure right yeah and then she and then i
hear that she accepted islam afterwards
and that's all through conduct bro
exactly not through words not through
forcing people to see your way like i
get it bro a lot of the time when people
accept islam
i know a lot of people bro that if
you're watching this
not attacking you it's just people in
general when they accept islam they have
this superiority complex
i get it you should be proud you should
be happy that you found the truth
but it's like think about it bro we went
all out of the room like that
you too were once in a phase of your
life where you didn't know the truth
where you were searching you were lost
like
anger was mentioning we are lost till we
find islam until
we find allah yeah and you were there
too i was there too we were all there
more times than not yeah so how are you
going to act like
now you find this you're holier than
thou and you judge other people and you
make them feel bad
and you make them feel bad for let's say
drinking
smoking yeah i'm saying these are sins
we all know that but it's like there's a
way
to get them away from these things you
don't shame them you don't be aggressive
and hostile and
make them feel bad then they're just not
gonna accept it right there's a way to
bring them closer to the truth
but if you feel if you see a brother
that's let's say i don't know doing
something that's haram
listen to music watching porn whatever
you want to call it there's so many
things that are you know permissible
there's a few things that are
impermissible so if he's doing or she's
doing one of these impermissible things
there's a way to you know carry yourself
to get them away from these things right
yeah and also bro shout out to rami for
going in
on episode number five where we talked
about the origins
and the story of the prophet sallam so
much more to tell people
spend their lives dedicated to this
topic but
i don't i don't get it man why is it one
of our least viewed
episodes so if you guys want to learn
more about the prophet sallam
um i'm sure so many people you know
accepted islam after the episode got
closer to allah got closer to
understanding the prophet
and rami broke everything down so
beautifully there's so many stories in
that so if you guys want to watch it
click on episode 5 we'll put it
somewhere here or down
in the description and yeah man let's
continue
inshallah on hill man i promise to give
it off to you and it was a bit delayed
but i want to hear
what you wanted to say dude i don't even
know
i have nothing to say right now okay we
were talking about
it was before emotional intelligence i
think it was about the three stages
you remember yeah yeah i remember that
do you remember what you were gonna say
after that
three stages
i did not it's okay my bad man i'll pass
it off sooner inshallah
but um subhan allah so
why do you think we're lacking emotional
intelligence today why do you guys think
we're
we're missing character and mannerisms
these days
um i'll go first remember the whole
three levels i talked about
yeah there's stages when you play a
video game you don't go from level one
to three
right i would say most people are sheep
they're blind
they've lost a deen they've lost any
sense of reality of this red pill
which basically means reality not no
filter right
they're level one and most people die in
the state of level one
this is a shame because how would you
have emotional intelligence bro
when all you're doing is just trying to
please other people you don't even have
a lot
first and foremost right so at the end
of the day
i feel like this is a big reason why a
lot of people lack
emotional intellect and if they do get
to level two it's still reactionary
right it's not islamic masculinity
that's why
they still lack it because they're like
i gotta be cold i gotta be bitter i
gotta be
always walking around me mugging right
but the few people that get to level
three
i don't think they like it bro yeah and
my last reason for honorable answers and
gives us two cents
of why people are lacking emotional
intelligence today
is because people around them
and most people are not carrying
themselves with conduct with morale
right i get it it's victim blaming but
at the end of the day if that's all you
see
doesn't that make a feedback loop and
then go into the next generation and the
next
right people are seeing men lose their
temper
you know women not being women and not
being men so
how could they have emotional
intelligence right 100
100 i feel like that's why alhamdulillah
just the three of us being friends
makes us better people because we pick
up on you know whatever
good that the other person has
subhanallah and i saw that a lot with
the with the trip to banff 100
it was honestly really life-changing for
me but on hill i believe you take it
away
yeah i'd say what i was going to say man
damn so you just we
lack yeah we lack those role models from
the beginning
but it's like if we have those clear-cut
role models
and i'm not just talking about men i'm
talking about women as well
if we see what an actual man is and we
see where the actual woman is
and we see these dynamics at play where
you can have like a father and a mother
but like a
proper father and a proper mother
yeah and then you go out into your
school and you also see
uh proper examples i feel like that
would just naturally develop men into
being men
and women to be women you know what i'm
saying versus like a man having to
decode the system and then figure it out
like
what 20s 30s 40s
dude some some guys are like 50 years
old still don't understand this
yeah it's kind of long what
what are we going to do about it i'm 50
what how do you parent
i i didn't i can't paint because i had a
bad dad what are we going to do about it
we'll answer all these questions guys
because at the end of the day people are
people are triggered people are
wondering okay like how can i how can i
be a good parent if i would never had a
good parent right
how can i be why should i learn how to
be a good parent if i don't have kids
myself
reality is more times than not you will
one day and
you only get one shot at it right that's
the thing with parenting
it's once it's done once they're grown
up if
you didn't push them off to the point
where they leave you you know inshallah
they won't
then they're just not gonna be close to
you you want a friend in your kids
and you want a friend in your parents
right you want a mom and dad
not just a biological father and a
biological mother right
if any so inshallah
do you two think we should get brother
gabriel
gabriel or brother abu to make an
episode since the actual fathers go they
have kids they have multiple kids
and we talk about you know how to be a
proper father
yeah to men or to boys and to girls
yeah i think that's something uh we
should get them on for a hundred percent
a hundred hundo and the viewers if you
if you guys agree
put that in the in the description down
below uh hashtag parenting
if if you made it this far and you think
we should bring them back for this
episode
sure no we're not even done and you're
already saying if you made it this far
100 well some people just go through the
timestamps and see what they're like you
know
so if they write it down we'll know the
real ones watch this
yeah that's true that's true subhanallah
um but yeah
just having that um you know that a role
model
like we mentioned before seeing it in
action
is so much greater than reading about it
or or
you know hearing about it because a lot
of the time when you see things
you know more of the context right than
if you just read about something
for example if you read about the
process and i'm saying something
you don't know the exact context in
which he said it how many people were
there when he said it
if it was to one person or an entire
group of people
um if there was if it was a response to
a question sometimes you don't even know
that
um how he acted the way he said it the
tony he had things like that
right all these things that are missing
you know if you were there to to witness
it yourself that's why the science of
hadith is so
um in-depth and specific and it must be
done by you know specialists
who know you know uh the the backgrounds
behind these things because the other
hadith
and so on and so forth and the
authenticity and stuff but if you see it
to yourself
your brain is processing so much more
that you may not even
think about you know at the forefront
but it's there and you realize and you
recognize it and you internalize it
that's why leading by example is so
important and the fact that we lack that
is such a big
problem because the prophet says in the
quran that he is an example
right he's the perfect example and this
is
why do you think they were the greatest
generation because they had
the greatest creations in them and why
do you think the greatest generation
after that
or the greatest generation was um like
after the sahabah were the ones after
them their children and then their
children
because they had the the closest
uh timeline to the prophet is in them
they were closest to him and the people
who were closest to him and the people
that were closest to them
right and nowadays fast forward 1400
years you know from
from then we've lost a lot of that and
it's because we don't have that that
character we don't have those role
models so
and this is what i've been trying to say
more recently when i talk about it we
need
role models like i'm talking about you
you two and myself and all the other
daddy's all the other muslims we need to
be those role models
um for these people we need to you know
try and emulate the prophet sam as much
as possible
and and be these role models that we
didn't have ourselves i think that's
that's fundamentally important
for all the muslims bro let me
explain this for people if they didn't
catch on to this in the uh
video we did with gabriel and i were
american
which romney wasn't there because me and
fire tucked him in the night before
we are creatures of observation
the moment we were born as babies what
did we do
like yeah we cried yeah we ate yeah we
you know we we pooped i'm not gonna say
the other word i was about to
i'm not gonna say it but we were just
observing everything
and when we observed we're processing
all this stuff that's coming in like a
computer
and like as we get older the things that
we're observing
we start to emulate and then as we
emulate
we start to kind of like develop our own
little
uh style our own little personality our
own little way with it but in reality we
are just a combination
of things that we have observed
processed and are now
emulated so it's like if if you can
understand that then you understand
how important it is to have these role
models in your life
at all stages doesn't matter when you're
a baby it doesn't matter if you're 50
years old at all stages
and you have to understand too in order
for
you to be the best role model
number one you have to work on
yourselves you got to be the best
version of yourself if you want to be
the best role model
and number two if you want to be the
best role model
like you have to learn to follow before
you can lead
and that's something that was like real
hard for me to accept because i used to
think to myself like nah i'm not a
follower i'm a leader but it's like dude
we were all followers before we became a
leader and the best
leaders in this world were followers
before they became a leader
man yo real quick that the whole point
you made about
uh monkey see monkey do creatures of
observation
how many parents do you know that tell
their kids to do one thing
but then they don't practice what they
preach
and then they get butt hurt when their
son or daughter
isn't doing what they're telling them
because they don't realize
your daughter your son they don't care
about what you say what do they see you
do
oh uh don't drink you know drinking is
bad
and they they somehow stumble into your
room and they find liquor in your locker
in your closet right you really think
they're gonna listen
or you know don't cuss you're too young
cussing is bad
and then they they go and they you know
they have a foul mouth
right the kids aren't gonna listen bro
shout out to you for almost cussing but
stopping yourself because about the same
patreon
you feel me we can't be can't be too
like that but uh
it's hard it's hard bro i get it it's a
personal battle for me too
but at the end of the day one thing with
parenting you know because that's going
to be a whole other episode
is you can't be out here and this is not
just parenting in general
you got to practice what you preach
right um
in the quran there's a verse that says
you you admonish others
for for sinning for doing these for
doing that
yet you forget it yourselves and you
read the book like come on like how are
you gonna
be out here preaching and and saying
this saying that judging putting up this
front but it's like behind closed doors
you're not praying
you're not you know you're not you're
eating when you're supposed to be
fasting
come on yeah and i get it bro you're
probably doing these things because you
saw
x y and z or your parents doing these
things growing up
but come on you're past 13 allah's gonna
hold you accountable
you know yes don't lead others as
straight but
keep yourself on the straight path first
yeah 100
100 max that's facts dude bro just think
about this
if we break it down in a very simple
example
let's say someone's playing basketball
right they're gonna look at like their
favorite basketball player let's say
their favorite basketball player is kobe
bryant
rest in peace man rest in peace i'd say
their favorite basketball player is kobe
bryant
and now they are trying to emulate kobe
bryant's moves
kobe bryant's mindset the way kobe
bryant trains every single day eight to
ten hours a day
it's like they will come
very close i'm not gonna say they're
gonna become kobe bryant because there's
only one kobe bryant
but they will become themselves like
they would become the greatest version
of themselves
but they were only able to do so because
they followed they observed they monkey
sea monkey do
yeah and like bro even think about it
too where it's like they tell you oh if
you want to get better
like bro let's say you want to be a
better fighter let's say you want to be
a better
a basketball player baseball player
soccer player whatever it is whatever it
is that you're doing let's say you want
to be the better
version of yourself the best player that
you can be
are you going to become the best player
you can be by playing with trash people
or you're going to be the best player
you can be by playing with people who
are better than you
and you get humble then you get beaten
all the time but you're constantly
observing
seeing all their moves
bro the way that they process things the
way that they act and the way they do
things to where it's like
dude you're gonna get to another level
where you probably would have never
gotten there if you were playing the
sorry people
yeah that's 100 true that's facts
there's something
you told me uh i think on a call a month
or two ago
and it's so good it's so true yeah and
you can see this in all aspects of life
if you do things with the greats you
know
um even if you're getting humbled right
every time you get humbled every time
you lose you're learning from that right
the the old saying when
uh winner learn right you never lose you
win or learn
um it's it's so true it's about allah
but the real losers are the ones who
don't have that mindset
right the real losers are the ones who
don't have that mindset what's the point
of being um
at the top of the lowest competition
right you get a false sense of
superiority um
you know you're not really improving
yourself
and that's that's maybe it's it's
arrogant maybe it's narcissistic maybe
it's whatever you got bro nice facts
you're right you want to be king of the
jungle you want to be king of the world
exactly you could surround yourself
among the weakest people
right let's be honest bro and i'm gonna
make a generalization so
trig alert but every single viewer
should be able to relate to this
you are definitely probably
the most you know trying to be closer to
allah
out of all of your peers trying to be uh
stronger
mentally trying to be smarter doing
something with your life you are more
more often times or not more likely than
not that person
that other people your friends are
looking up to
you are most probably not most likely
not the worst
of your peer group why because it's
uncomfortable to position yourself
where you're making less money than
those around you where you're not in
school and everyone else is in school
where everyone else is getting trying to
get closer to allah and spread the
message of islam
and you know you don't want to be that
person that's less because your ego
will know that in this mental hierarchy
you are beneath
everyone but it's only putting yourself
constantly around those that are better
than you
then you can climb that ladder you know
but two examples man
i remember when i first started playing
call of duty and like my boys here y'all
know
y'all know we play call of duty not man
yeah but um when i first started playing
like i think i was a kid man like i was
afraid to like
play online multiplayer because like
everyone was so much better and like
i didn't want to die all the time so i
just started playing with bots
and like bro i did the same thing bro i
played i played with boss for like
i think a week and i was like oh like
i'm good bro i'm good like i was like
beating all the butts
and i was like you know what i think i'm
ready i think i'm ready for uh
multiplayer and when i played online bro
i then went like zero and 17 bro
let me be honest you probably didn't
even use veteran bots
nah they were on recruit same same here
bro because you want that false sense of
security you probably have
200 and all yeah and at the end of the
day
what is that going to do because you
know in the back of your mind
you're being a worse because there's
this whole world of actual players
with better kds than you and you're
choosing to take these right
that's fine yeah you can be a king of a
little hill but wouldn't you be the king
of the mountain
is it going to take more work yeah is it
harder yeah but won't
more people see you when you're up there
yeah so won't you have more limelight
and spotlight to spread the message of
islam
positivity whatever you want to do with
your life of course so
do the work bro and for men watching
this
you don't peak nearly as as fast as
women
right women are at their peak at their
best at their top
you know best version of themselves way
earlier
than men they they start puberty before
us
their uh their you know biological peak
is earlier too you know you can watch a
video about sajid
um brother sajid which uh you know
alhamdulillah is doing really good for
the community and he talked about
you know message to muslim women very
good video um if you want to get more
info on that
but men don't peak till they're 30. so
don't don't be
30 only having played with raccoon bots
wondering why you're not good right
realize it's okay it's gonna take time
right
bro i'm 23. rami is 20.
angel is 26.
we are nowhere near our peak and it's
okay
but are we doing things about it little
things every day day in and day out of
course
but do we realize we're not all gonna be
that friend you were talking about
that's 20 years old or or your age or
our age
has his life together financially free
can retire right now we're not gonna do
that
right um quick uh quick sneak peek right
now
uh we're gonna upload a video on finance
coming up real soon
so if you also made it this far type in
hashtag
bitcoin
um this this really is really ties into
a video
that on hill is working on which i'm not
going to spoil now
but i want to shout it out because when
he told me about the the concept behind
it
it's so fundamentally important and
again go ahead and go ahead and shut it
out i was like one now like what are you
talking about i'm not working on a video
right now
but uh i remember i told you go ahead
yeah it didn't drop yet right
no i haven't made it but i don't mind if
you talk about it here all right
what are you subscribe to relate it to
or like
connect it to yeah so i feel like a lot
of people are going to
to you know hear this that we should aim
to be at the top
right and they're gonna instantly be
like maybe i shouldn't and they're gonna
lose before they even start um but then
i thought about what you told me you
know
decide make the plan and just go all out
yeah right okay yeah yeah so let me let
me break this down let me uh
reverse engineer yeah a little bit here
for a second
so what we were talking about was
emotional intelligence
and then we were saying how like okay
well emotional intelligence comes from
proper role models
proper men and proper women and then
it goes into the fact okay how do you
become a proper man how do you become a
proper woman that's
being the greatest version of yourself
but now in order for you to be the
greatest version of yourself you have to
have
um we all know what the purpose of this
life is
but you have to have something else that
like you you're doing in this life that
you're aiming towards a passion
that you're striving for and that you're
working towards every single day
you know what i mean like whether you're
a man or a woman both are going to be
different but you still need to have a
passion yet you now have something that
you're going towards
because that's going to ultimately give
your life
this uh i guess grounding
fulfillment it just makes it all connect
together piece together perfectly
you know i mean like you can't have you
can't be a proper man
and you can't be a proper woman if you
have no purpose
it also gives you money bro so you could
survive facts facts
it gives you money but it goes without
saying that you need
that purpose so first off
find out what it is that's your purpose
what are you going to do
so we'll use a very simple example here
let's say someone wants to be
a professional basketball player
okay this is where you got to ask
yourself okay now i want to be a
professional basketball player
how am i going to be a professional
basketball
player and that's where the acronym
drss comes in it basically means
decide so you've already decided
you've already decided okay i want to be
a professional basketball player
but you have to really decide you have
to be 100 and it can't be like oh i kind
of
want to do this but i kind of want to do
this over here you know it has to be
like look this is what i want to do
and this is what i'm going to do 100 so
you decide
then you reverse engineer so with the
reverse engineering
you are basically imagining yourself
as if you were already that professional
basketball player and then
you start breaking it down step by step
as to how you got there
in the best possible way that you can it
might not be 100
it but it's going to give you some
framework it's going to give you
something to
uh follow you know it's going to give
you some kind of direction some path
here
and then that'll lead you to where it's
like okay well now i know what steps i
have to take and now once you know what
steps you have to take
you got to decide you got the reverse
engineer now you have
show up like there's a lot of times
you're gonna feel emotional you might
feel like oh man i
wanna get a few more hours of sleep um
ah you know what like
i wanna spend time with my girl today or
i wanna
i wanna play some video games i just
want to relax i don't want to do
anything today you know what i'm really
depressed
i'm really sad i'm really anxious or
something like that i i don't want to
train i don't want to do this today
i like you have to show up no matter how
you feel no matter what's going on in
your life
you have to show up all right and then
once you show up
right you got three here you got the drs
the last one
is show out because once you show up bro
you show
out you do the best that you can and
even if it's not a hundred percent
it's better than if you were sitting at
home doing nothing
and it's always a step in that in that
direction so bro
before you know you're a professional
basketball player and before you know
you are a proper man or proper woman
yeah and before you know it now you are
this role model
yeah everyone else in your life 100
subhanallah i'm glad you you really
linked it back to the core
um of being a role model at the end of
the panel because i was going to say the
reason
uh i you know i inquired about this uh
during the recording during this podcast
is because
you have to be really mentally strong to
be able to do that right
anyone can tell themselves that okay no
matter how i feel i'm gonna do it
but when the time comes you actually
have to be that person
you have to be that man or woman that
actually shows you know shows up and
then shows out on top of it
because the first thing i thought of was
okay yeah maybe i'll uh i'll go to uh
my my jujitsu class or whatever i'm
doing i don't do gtc yet but in
charlotte soon
uh you know what i'll lay it up you know
whatever i'm doing but i'll just be a
bit sloppy i'll be a bit lazy right my
mind will be preoccupied
but to then show out meaning you know
you give it your all and stuff
that's a whole other level of strength
and you need that emotional
uh emotional intelligence essentially
because
uh you need to to be able to regulate
your own emotions whether it's it's you
know
sadness depression grief anxiety
whatever it is you need to be able to
regulate those
unless it's like some severe disorder
you need you know actual help
i'm not replacing this any you know
professional advice or anything
but if you're not that point then you
regulate those emotions and
just like the brothers said you get to a
point where now people are looking up at
you
and looking towards you for inspiration
you can inspire others
subhanallah fundamentally important
dude and on a side note yeah if you just
show up
dude magic happens when you show up
like even if you're not doing anything
even if you just show up like let's say
you're just stupid tired like bro your
body's just so
sore and you know you need to recover
you know
you can't train right now if you still
show up to your training but you don't
train you're just sitting there watching
and observing
ooh bro like so much more could happen
that you wouldn't have been
exposed to if you didn't show up that's
facts
that's facts man showing up inside the
battle
yeah that's true that's true yeah
subhanallah
um you want to wrap it up
yeah yeah inshaallah i was just going to
say it leads back to um
environmental psychology just being in
that you know that situation and seeing
these things uh
you know what will do you wonder um it's
it's a part of the reason why fleeing
from the battlefield is one of the worst
things
because not only are you running away
you're showing everyone else that maybe
it's okay to run away
you see one person run you know i was
actually i was out with a group of
friends uh
you know in my jahilia days and um we
were out friday night lights fired if
you remember that the football games and
all that stuff saint marcelinus and
you know all that stuff and
police usually pull up because people
are usually doing some dumb things
one guy starts running the full group of
30 men
start just bolting it it starts
sprinting
nothing's even happening imagine on a
battlefield subhanallah so
you know it goes to show you really need
to uh to surround yourself with good
people insha'allah so may allah make us
you know good people surrounded with
good people and make us leaders for the
righteous and make us good role models
and allow us to emulate the prophet
sallallahu alaihi
and make us you know the best of men and
the best of women
i mean i mean i mean bro to talk your
point people got to just do the damn
work
yeah do what you said you were going to
do write it down and follow through too
many people are not following too
look at the battle of a wonderful
example of you know
a a fight that we lost as muslims
they were we were supposed to be uh
there were some some archers right they
were supposed to they they knew that
there was a role
they had to be archers but it's like
they then decided oh no we should not do
this or it's it's
you know we already won or you know when
when you
have this false pretense that you don't
have to do what you got to do
bro come on things only goes up good
example of this is if you write things
down that you got to do the next day
you wake up the next day and you're like
oh it's it's it's raining outside i'm
cold
or i don't want to leave the bed or you
know i'll just do this the next day
and like the next day i'll do that these
things and to these things and i'll
combine these things
come on you're you're only setting
yourself up for failure right it's
always like
first thing you wake up in the morning
you're in an altered state
right you're in an altered state of
neural chemistry
like i know says you it's i'm not gonna
say you're as if you're under the
influence of a drug
but it's like the next worst thing right
because
the first few seconds when you wake up
yeah out of your attitude
you're not grounded when you were
sensical the night before
you set out to do these things and
that's
the real you the real you would follow
through with these things right but
in the morning i get it you're not
you're not all there so you kind of make
rationalizations to why you shouldn't do
this common reason why people always
sleep through alarms
right because if only they knew the
night before they would have woken up
but
they don't know how they're going to
feel in the morning right yeah so
also why people do dumb things when they
when they're under the influence or they
they're drunk or high you get what i
mean so when you're in a proper state
set guidelines set boundaries things to
do
and it doesn't matter how you feel in
the moment follow through
it doesn't matter if you got to do
something you got if you
are at a position in a battle that's you
don't
try to be something else don't try to
identify something else be the best that
you could be
with the role that allah gave you based
on your sex based on your
um circumstances based on your abilities
talents whatever allah has blessed you
with allah as always
allah has blessed everyone with
something wouldn't you guys agree
it's just a matter till we find it and
then thrive 100 yeah yo on the side no
not that raw man i'm gonna cut you off
here but um
on a side note it's real interesting
that um if you focus your effort your
attention only on one thing throughout
the entire day
do you know that you would dream about
that thing
you ever had it where like you you were
just so obsessed about something maybe
it was like
some girl maybe it was a video game some
tv show or something like that
and so you spend the entire day just
focus on that and then when you went to
sleep it's like you actually dreamed
about that
yeah bro when i was doing uh the
dopamine detox for the first time
and like literally like my whole day
consisted of just martial arts
martial arts martial arts martial arts
bro and it's like i think i would spend
maybe like 30 minutes or an hour working
you know mashallah bro alhamdulillah but
the entire day just doing martial arts
and bro i would go to sleep and i would
dream
about martial arts i would wake up out
of my sleep
doing like a kick or something like that
like y'all felt that didn't you
did y'all feel that right there bro i
would wake up like doing a kick
i would wake up like punching the bed or
something like that it
it just goes to show how like
we can affect our sleep and our sleeping
pattern and what we dream about to where
it's like okay you said oh you wake up
and you're kind of out of it bro i would
wake up and i was alert bro
i was alert i was on it bro have you
looked into the psychology of day
residue
day residue being the things that we
accumulate through the day that stays
you know resides in the back that we
dream
right it all goes through your focus
well i'm not saying if you're consumed
with one thing
that's gonna be you know how you affect
your subconscious mind
right it's not gonna be through you know
big things it's the little things right
because there's many little things
right quick point i want to i want to
mention right now
um i feel like every human being
should know what the prophet sallam
looks like
and a lot of you didn't know but it's
possible we see the prophet
of wasallam in a dream it is very
possible that we can see him in a dream
right rami why should we even see him in
a dream
subhanallah seeing the prophet said him
in a dream if you see him you know as he
is as he's described um
then you've seen him prosthetic said if
you see me in a dream then it was really
me
so if you see some guy like low riding
or like you know smoking or drinking it
and he says across it i said i'm it's
not it's [ __ ] on this guy
a hundred percent um but singapore said
i sent him in a dream is one of the most
beautiful blessings you know you you
could get from a dream
um i've never had one inshallah one day
may allah you know bless us all with
that
um i've heard stories of like young
girls and like like little kids and all
these people's panel that seem to see
the falsehood i saw my dream but
one of the greatest blessings man
imagine seeing him
yeah there is a book thousands of people
have read this book
all it is is a compilation of hadith
that describe his appearance
talking about his seal talking about his
height talking about his beard his hair
everything to the core the degree of
any type of physicality that you can
imagine yeah
even his walk even non-physical things
now so many people have
read this before bed numerous times and
then they dream about
the prophet sallallahu alaihi and it's
an amazing feeling bro so
you know yeah insha'allah in jannah
we're chilling with the prophet
sallallahu salaam he's telling us
stories about everything but
come on we can do this now at the very
least even if you don't dream
and you're not capable of achieving that
which again it's all through allah
you'll know what he looks like you have
this mental prototype
of of the prophet anyway why not see if
how we actually look like alliance with
that
and what's surprising is most people
have told me after reading this book
the picture they had already looked like
y'all froze big time really
you're me and romy have been fun yeah
maybe you're logging out maybe you're
lagging bro we we saw your profile
picture and then you just lost it
yeah i don't think you can hear us
anymore
yeah we can't see you but yeah
yo with that being said uh romney
let's uh tie off your point then just in
this call you shot lunch allah but
were did you finish saying what you're
saying first i want to get that book
inshallah so please afford it to me but
yeah oh bro i'll just put i'll put the
pdf in the description
okay i'll put it for everyone watching
so come on man y'all have four hashtags
right now you got you got
the bitcoin one you got the the you know
hashtag level 3 if you made it this far
also throwing another hashtag
which was the first one and this last
one if you truly made it to this point
ana's already here
hashtag profit right and at the end of
the
day
if we have like for me it's just a
personal goal bro
if i see a dream of the prophet salaam
well i'll know
and the people that that have had it
subhanallah man i know what is so funny
okay
perfect timing man you saw make that
make that stupid face bro and then just
yeah
what is this subhanallah but uh all
right
well it's t2m now uh with that being
said
may allah allah see the process i said
i'm in a dream uh
yeah for joining us for this episode
um i think it's fundamentally important
this one as well um
with that being said
[Music]
they use this money as a tool to benefit
themselves in this life to be able to
plant for the hiraka this is what the
the true muslim does and even i was i
was very happy when when khabib
started becoming more successful he
started with several charity projects
and and africa and things like that
that's what someone is supposed to do
when he when allah subhanahu wantana
you know bless him with with wealth and
with fame
but the really thing that really you
know is and from the benefits that
really kind of you know
what sticked out to me when i i did this
about 54 things we benefit
is the issue of you know the honor
and not being shy not compromising
and he's in and we talked about this
before as well about the
the muslims who are too shy to practice
their faith the ones who
always want to compromise and and and
and do things that are haram in order to
please other people
and you look now for just the the clip
that went you know went around recently
about
you know him not shaking hands we've
seen it several times where he doesn't
shake hands
and not compromising this is what our
religion teaches us we don't shake hands
with the opposite gender
not not compromising when when when the
the lady
in riyadh of all places i you know asked
him about
um you know then how a woman can be
successful
as a fighter and what did he say to her
you know to be to be a fighter in your
house
didn't compromise this is his belief
system that this is where the woman
should be focusing is on her house and
her family he's not going to say now
because i'm successful in this
and the right thing to say as an as an
enemy championship
is how you can do it as a woman is to do
this and this and this and to do this
and this and to train like this and
he didn't he didn't compromise he said
right away that you know
you should fight in your house that's
where you should fight this is where you
should be raising the children
the societies have been corrupted why
because the women are are not with their
children in their houses they're out
with
chasing their careers and the houses are
being destroyed and even muslim
households as well as they're following
in the footsteps so he didn't compromise
in several examples
i remember in the mentioned some things
uh you know he always made it clear that
his faith came first
ufc 200 which at that time was the
biggest ever you know this was the
biggest event
it was in ramadan he was like no i'm not
taking part in it he was very clear
wasn't willing to compromise even though
he needed that stepping stone in his
career during that time as
one of the biggest stepping stones for
him would have been usc 200 but he
refused to take part because
it was in ramadan and he also did even
like something small
to us maybe when the the
reporter said and he had said to him and
whiskey like in the same sentence
and he stopped them and he said don't
don't say those two together.
even though any would we say that
something and the reporter didn't mean
anything negative by it right
but he said just don't mix those two
words together okay he was always in a
sudden
he's not shy to explain how he believes
and always
you know attaching to allah subhanahu wa
tala you know saying that says it's a
lie you know
[Music]